Evet efendim bu toplantının konusu neden
Onun için ben de neden hayatın Hakkını
Verelim başlığını seçtim iyi mi mi
neresi olduğunu biliyorsunuz bunu Burası
iki mayaların Everest Tepesi 8848 metre
insan fizyolojisinin sınırı Burası 200
metre daha yüksek olsa çıkmak mümkün
olmayacaktı 200 metre daha düşük olsaydı
çok daha fazla kişi çıkacaktı insanlar
bu dağ 18 yoldan çıkılıyor aşağı yukarı
kırk gün sürüyor Bu daha çıkış yani
vücudun alışması için fizyolojik olarak
O 30 lira 60 bin dolara mal oluyor bu
yolculuğa çıkmak Yani buraya çıkan
insanlar aslında ceplerinden para Taşan
insanlar değil Bunu Hedef koyup uzun
zaman para biriktiriyor lar ve aynı
zamanda da kendilerine hazırlıyorlar
fizyolojik olarak da hazırlıyorlar Ve
sonunda bu yolculuğa çıkıyorlar
Çıktıkları zaman vardıklarında tepeye
bir resim çektiriyorlar mutlaka mutlaka
Yok yok ondan sonra indikleri zaman
söyledikleri şey çok ilginç diyorlar ki
Ben artık eski insan değilim bundan
önceki ben değilim bu sadece fizyolojik
ve bedensel bir yolculuk değildi bu esas
olarak box zihinsel ve ruhsal bir
yolculuktu bu beni değiştirdi
dönüştürdüğü Çünkü sahip oldukları fizik
özellikler zindelik zaman içinde
kaybolsada Aslında geriye bu zihinsel ve
ruhsal zindelik kalıyor buraya aynı
şekilde bir başka yoldan da gidip resim
çektirmek mümkün DNS çıktın mı çıktım
resim çektirdim mi çektirdim şimdi bu
iki yolculuğu yapan insan aynı insan
değil tahmin edebileceğiniz gibi Aslında
ben şimdi inebilirim Benim mesajım bu
bu yolculuğun kendisi için ne kadar emek
veriyoruz ne kadar hakkını veriyoruz
o Çünkü hakikaten bir mucizeyiz pekiz
biri ciyiz sizden benden başka bir tane
daha benzeri yok 9 trilyon da bir
ihtimal sizin Siz benim ben olma
ihtimalim ve bu Milli Piyango'nun bir
hayat boyu dokuz defa çıkmasına eşit
İmkansız ama böyle bir mucize olmak bak
hak etmediğimiz şeylere sahip olma
hakkını bize vermiyor Emek vermeden
zirveye ulaşmak veya sadece okulları ve
diplomaları bitirerek diplomalarını
alarak o zirveye ulaşmak hayatın hakkını
vermeye yetmiyor Şimdi yaşam süresi
Üzerine Bazı yaygın uygulamaların neler
olduğuna şöyle bir göz atarsak çok yakın
zamanda yapılan bir araştırmanın
sonucunda Yani temiz hava almak kilosuna
dikkat etmek Düzenli egzersiz yapmak
Oh buz ki ne kadar düşük korelasyon
içinde
O sigarayı bırakmak güle En üste iki
tane madde var Bunlardan bir tanesi aile
ve arkadaşlarla yakın ilişkiler yer
ilginç bir şey bir tanesi de aile ve
arkadaşlar dışındaki insanlarla
kurduğumuz bağlar ben şimdi zamanın
elverdiği ölçüde bu bana ayrılan sürenin
sonunda size üç şeyi Anlatmaya
çalışacağım birincisi Sağlıklı ve uzun
yaşamak için insanlarla kurmamız gereken
ilişki biçimini ikincisi başarı için
ödemeniz gereken Bedeli 3 üçüncüsü de
çok peşinde olduğumuz mutluluk için
anlamlı bir hayata giden yolda atılması
gereken birkaç küçük adımı Anlatmaya
çalışacağım bakalım zaman ne kadarına
izin verecek şimdi Burada gördüğünüz fil
iki buçukta üzerindeki Binici ise işte
bir kilo bir an için film böyle gitmek
istediğini ama sürücüsünün de onu bu
tarafa yönlendirmek istediğini düşünün
ödül vermek işte canını yakmak ceza
vermek bunların yürümeyeceğini tahmin
ediyorsunuz aralarında bir ilişki olması
lazım Lütfen bu resme uzun bakın Çünkü
buradaki Binici akıl ve mantığı temsil
ediyor altındaki fil de duyguyu
o insanlarla ilgili kurduğumuz her türlü
ilişkide bunu bu benzetmeyi gözünüzün
önünden ayırmayın Biz istanbullular'ın
Aşina olduğu bir manzaradır bu Bu çok
sık olmasa da rastlarız köprünün
üzerinden birisi ayağını uzatır
atlayacağım Vera devlet büyüklerinden
biri geçmiyorsa yakınından arkadan
birisi gelir bir neredesin decay dersin
Neredesin deca edersin
var ya atta Demek ki fikir değil Çünkü
bunu diyen Onun için bir kere daha
düşünebilirsiniz Çünkü bunu diyenler
çıkıyordu bir kere daha düşünün Şimdi
burada genel olarak söylenen şeyler
değmez hayat güzel dünyada güzel şeyler
var Derdini anlat seni anlıyorum sıkıntı
dasın empati Hani biraz evvel akan
anlattı empati gösteririm şimdi noktaya
çıkmış olan bir insanın akılla mantıkla
ilgisi yok O noktaya çıkmış olan bir
insana ne yapmak lazım
bir duygu dünyasına gidecek bir mesaj
vermek lazım Beni bu konuda zihnimi
aydınlatan zihinsel bir aydınlanma
yaşamama sebep olan kişiyi seçili bir
psikolog George koli sır katıldığınız
bir toplantıda kendi meslek hayatından
anlattığı bir hikaye rehineleri
Kurtarmak üzere aldığı bir eğitim Rehine
müzakerecisi silahlı insanların elinden
rehineleri alıyor döktü dünyanın en
kolay yeşildir öğrendikten sonra zor
olan psikolojik olarak Rehine düşmüş
olanları kurtarmaktır diyor bu da
aklınızda bulunsun şimdi bu bir çağrı
alıyorlar ustasıyla gidiyor meslek
hayatının başında çocukların velayeti
yüzünden yaşanan bir çatışma üzerine eşi
tarafından yaralanmış bir siyah
Amerikalı Sema acil serviste hemşire yi
eline geçirdiği bir ameliyat bıçağıyla
makasıyla rehin almış ve çocuklarını
getirin Yoksa onu
Evet hocam kendimi öldüreceğim diyor
akıl ve mantık ne diyoruz ya Ne
yapıyorsun Aklından zorun var işte iki
çocukları hiç göremeyeceksin var adamı
hakikaten aklından zoru var psikolojik
bir duruma girmiş bu çocuğun söylediği
şu
O çocukların şu işe neler
Ya ben yok kendimi de öldüreceğim zaten
diyor Bunlar da öldüreceğim üstüne
gelirsen seni döndüreceğim çocuklarına
intihar etmiş katil bir baba olma
mirasını mı bırakacaksın bununla mı
yaşamalarını istiyorsun bu yükleme
deyince sen geri adım atıyor Bundan
sonrasını hızla özetliyorum
O elindeki makası bana verirsin masanın
üzerine bırakırsın Polisler geldi Onları
mı teslim olursun bana mı teslim olursun
tedavi niçin kelepçe takılması lazım
önden mi takılmasını istersen Arkadan mı
takılmasın istersin Yani sen bizi artık
teslim oldun elimizde sin ne söylersek
onu yapacaksın değil Şimdi georgen
yaptığı nedir sene gördüğün yaptığı s m
o
bu onun önem verdiği şeye önem verdiğini
gösterdi bunun adı bağ kurmaktır bu
empatiyi içine alan ve ötesine geçen bir
kavramdır Dolayısıyla Buradaki en kritik
nokta Yani insanlar Türkiye'de empatiden
artık biraz gına geldi alerji yaratmaya
başladı akan arkadaşımız çok güzel
anlattı Yani herkes empatiden söz ediyor
buradaki kavram empatiyi bir adım daha
ileriye götürmek karşımızdakinin önem
verdiği şeye önem verdiğimizi göstermek
kek ergenlik döneminde çocukları olan
anneler babalar var mı göremiyorum Yani
bir varsa onları anlayışlı davranın el
kaldıranlara öğretmenler kimler
öğretmenler meslektaşlarım onlar
öğrencilerinizle kurduğunuz ilişkide
bu yöneticiler var mı insan yönetenler
asların ızla kurduğunuz ilişkide Hayatın
her alanında ihtiyaç duyduğumuz şey bağ
kurmak hayatı en çok uzatan neydi
hatırlayın Bir önceki grafikte o sosyal
ilişkiler içinde yani bir kere bile
ilişki kurduğumuz insanlarla Onlara
kendilerini önemli hissettirecek bir
ilişki kurmak yani Sağlıklı ve uzun
yaşamanın en önemli anahtarı inanın
sosyal ilişkilerimizi sosyal
becerilerimiz onun arkasında da Bağ
kurmak var bilgi davranışı değiştirmez
buradan giderken benim sunucumdan bir
mesaj götürmek istiyorum götüreceksiniz
lütfen bu olsun bilgi davranışı
değiştirmez bilgi davranışı değiştirecek
olsa dünyada sigara içen bir tane insan
bulamazsınız sigarayı bırakanlara sorun
niye bıraktınız diye hepsi sağlığım için
der Ama arkasında
iki tane psikologların derinlemesine
görüşme dediği yöntemle soru sorarsanız
ne çıkar ya eşi için bırakır insanlar
sigarayı Ben öyle bıraktım büyük
çoğunluğu çocukları için bırakır
erkekler çoğunlukla kız çocukları için
bırakır bazıları da artık yaşı gereği
torunları için bırakın kırk yıl içtik
yeter işte bundan sonra torunlarımızın
keyfini sürelim diye yani bilgi
davranışı değiştirmez nasıl bağ
kurabiliriz insanlarla En azından
zihninizde gözünüzün önünde bulunması
için size birkaç tane yöntem söyledim
sonucunun klasik olmasına aldırış
etmeden Buradaki en önemli olan
faktörlerden bir tanesinin son madde
olduğunu düşünüyorum Çünkü herkesin
ağzında bir yoğunluk var Çok yoğunum çok
yoğunum demek dolaylı olarak ne demektir
bir yaklaşma demektir uzak dur sana
baktım yok Evet onun için bunlar
yardımcı olabilir
ve bu 1 bölüm 2 bölüm ne görüyorsunuz
Bu bir ağaç nasıl bir ağaç bozkırda
yetişmiş kurak Çorak bir yerde çok
kuvvetli rüzgara rağmen
O iyiymiş ama kırılmış
biz buna karşılık
bu Burada gördüğünüz ağaçlar
O çok daha hafifti rüzgarla yerle bir
neden
bu çünkü bozkırdaki ağaç
bu hayatta kalabilmek için köklerini
Derine salmış
bu suyun kenarındaki ağaç Hayat kolay
bu yüzeyde der Rüzgar geldiği zaman da
almış aşağı yıkmış Hayat başarısının
arkasındaki en önemli özellik
dayanıklılık yılmazlık ve bunun
sonucunda meydana gelen Öz yeterlidir
bu Özgüven meselesi beni bunaltıyor Ben
yüksek Güven kendine güven manyaklar da
psikopatlarda When a Sizler de vardır
Kendine güven ve kendine güven kendine
güven sahip olmadığı özelliklere sahip
olduğuna inanmak sahip olduklarında
abartmak tır Amerikan psikolojisinin
kolaylığından bize transfer olmuştur
başarılı olan insanların insanlar
özgüveni ya kendine güvendiği için
başarılı olmaz başarılı olan insanlar
kendilerine güvenir dolayısıyla da
genellikle bilimle uğraşma yanlar iki
şey birbirini izliyorsa bunu birbirinin
sebebi zannederler Onun için Esas mesele
yeterli liktir yeterli olabilmesi için
de insanın
ne düşmesi kalkması ve başarısız olması
gerekir Bir Türk toplumu başarıyla
zehirlenmiş bir toplum Dolayısıyla
başarısızlıktan Ödümüz patlıyor
başarısızlık paçalarından akıyor ama
başarısızlıkta Ödümüz patlıyor onun
içinde Onun içinde sınırlarınızı
Zorlayacak hiçbir işe girmiyoruz
sınırlarınızı Zorlayacak bir işe
girmediğimiz zamanda o zaman vasatın
içinde kendi potansiyeli ve kapasitesini
gerçekleştirmemiş insanlar olarak
kalıyoruz yaşam becerileri hayatın
içinde gelişir hayatın içinde gelişir
mücadele ederek gelişir vuruşarak
Gecikir düşerek ve kalkarak gelişir
düşerek ve kalkarak geçip gelişir
Dolayısıyla düşmeden kalkmadan başarısız
olmadan acı yaşamadan üzüntü yaşamadan
hayatta başarılı olmak gerçek anlamda
everest'in tepesine giden yolculuğu
yapmadan oraya pa
bu ve hatta işte helikopterle gitmeye
benzer o sebeple başarı için mutlaka
bedeli demek gerekir Nedeni belli
olmaksızın tekim Biriciğim bir taneyim
dolayısıyla da herşeye sahip olmam
gerekir gibi bir düşünce yanlıştır Bedel
ödemediğiniz Emek vermediğimiz Herhangi
bir şeye sahip olmaya hakkımız yok
Sizler çok özel insanlarsınız seçilmiş
insanlarsınız Buraya gelmişsiniz
Türkiye'nin binde birini bile değil on
binde birini temsil ediyorsunuz
e Okul arkadaşlarınızın arasında Mahalle
arkadaşlarınızın arasında sizin
yerinizde olmak için can atan insanlar
var Dolayısıyla bu Bedel ödemeyi göze
aldığınız zaman ve kendi hayatınızı daha
mutlu ve başarılı yaşamak için daha
mutlu yaşamak için hazırım mutluluk
olmadığının farkına vardığınızda çok
daha anlamlı bir hayat yaşayacaksınız
Çünkü esas olarak insanlar hazzı
mutluluk zannediyorlar anlık ve geçici
olan bunun içinde yemek hoş vakit
geçirmek kendini iyi hissetmek anı yaşa
carpe diyen My full siyah üzüm Al eline
her tarafını Hisset sesini Hisset
kokusunu Hisset tadını Hisset anı yaşa
al al şimdi kötü bir şey olduğu için
söylemiyorum ama andan ibaret değil
mutluluk bu paranın satın aldığı hazza
dönek you mutluluk bu cinselliğin
getirdiği hazza delikli mutluluk ve
bu çocuklar yaşandıktan sonra Kısa bir
süre duygunluk Ondan sonra yeniden
ihtiyaç doğurur Dolayısıyla geniş su
içerek susuzluğunu gidermeye benzer
hazza dönük mutluluk ikinci düzey
mutluluk kitap okurken zamanı kaybetmek
Hayat tırmanışı yaparken zamanı
kaybetmek bir arkadaşla girdiğiniz derin
bir sohbete futbol Ve Siyaset dışında
zamanı kaybetmek bunun içinde denize de
yemeğimizi bedenimize ve zihnimize
yatırım yapmanız gerekir kendiliğinden
olmaz Bir konserde zamanı kaybetmek buna
akış halindedir İngilizce Mutluluk nedir
biliyorsunuz hepiniz hangi kelimeyle
akraba happın Eylem yani Eylem içinde
mutluluk 3. düzeyde mutluluk kendini
aşan bir amaca hizmet etmekle elde
edilen mutluluk kendini aşağıya bir
amaca hizmet etmek ve elde edilen
mutluluk bir sizden daha şanslı olan
insanlara kendinizi borçlu
o zamanınızı ve bütçenizin bir bölümünü
onlar için kullanmanız demektir bunun
için aile sofrasında kaç aldın Kaçıncı
olduğun su körü neresindesin daha çok
çalış daha öne geçin ötesinde bir
sohbete ihtiyaç var ki bu sohbet Vicdan
geliştirir Vicdan geliştirir Vicdan
Kendinden başka insanları düşünmeyi
gerektirir kibarlık ve nezaket
başkalarını rahatsız etmemek değildir
başkalarının rahatsızlığından
rahatsızlık duymaktır bunun içinde
Vicdan gelişimine ihtiyaç vardır ve
vicdan azap vermek için vardır azap
vermeyen ve rahatlatan vicdan olmaz onun
için eğer bir vicdan azabı vermiyorsa
rahatlatıyor sağa orada vicdan yok
aydınlarda toplumun vicdanıdır onlarında
toplumu rahatsız etmesi ve az
2'si beklenir Dolayısıyla toplumdaki
otorite ile bütünleşen Otoritenin hoşuna
gidecek şeyleri söyleyip ezilenlerin
yanında yer almayan bir Aydın vicdanına
da Aydın vicdanı denmez ne denir
herkesten dizilerinden adını koyabilir
Amerika'da ve İngiltere'de büyük
gazeteler ölüm haberleri yayınlarlar
obituaries bazıları bir sayfadır
bazıları kısacık Amerikalı bir
matematikçi gelecek trendlerini ölçen
bir matematikçi sabah kahvaltısında 18
ay boyunca mm tane ilanı topluyor ve üç
gruba ayrılıyor birinci gruptakiler
herkesin tanıdığı insanlar bunlar bilim
adamları devlet adamları politikacılar
her gruptan insanlar sanatçılar Tabii ki
Bu akademisyenler ikinci gruptakiler
kimsenin bilmediği Nisa yani okuyunca
kimsenin tanımadığı Ama biraz daha
okuyunca ha dedirten insanlar bunlar
hayatlarının bir döneminde önemli bir
katkı yapmışlar mesleklerinde bir an
için düşünün insanına meslek hayatındaki
Zirve kaç yaş olabilir
bu 37 Bu grupta Bunlar 81 yaşında ölmüş
44 yıl önce yaptıklarıyla
hatırlatıyorlar
Ben 37 yaşında yakın olanları aldığı bir
düşünce benim bu hikaye anlatmamın
sebebi 3. kurup Bunlar kimsenin
tanımadığı insanlar ve ölüm ilanları 4
satıraltı satır Ama en çok tekrarlanan
kelime bı kelimesinden sonra İngilizce
hep yardım et tipi ölümden sonra
hatırlanmak için mutlaka İnsanların
hayatına bir şey katmak gerekiyor
dolayısıyla bir demin konuştuğumuz
konuları aynı şekilde
bu iş hayatında da sorabiliriz insanlara
kendilerinin dışında birilerinin
varlığını o insanlara karşı sorumluluğu
olduğunu evde hissettirmeye başlarsak iş
hayatında daha kolay hissettirir izâ
çok kısa bir video Onlar bu var
[Müzik]
abone ol
bu çocuklarımıza da birlikte
çalıştığımız insanlara da başarının tek
başına olacak bir şey değil başkalarıyla
birlikte olabilecek bir şey olduğunu
anlatırsak çok daha anlamlı ve değerli
bir hayat sunmuş oluruz onları Böyle bir
hayatı hazırlamış oluruz herkes iyi
yaşamak istiyor herkes güzellikleri
istiyor hayatın içinde sevgi var aşk var
diplomalar var bir doğum günleri var
Mutlu Arkadaş toplantıları var ama aynı
zamanda hayatın içinde sevgisizlik var
ihanet var başarısızlık var bir hayatın
içinde acı üzüntü ızdırap hayal
kırıklığı utanma yoksa o hayat mantarlı
hayattır o hayatında hikayesi olmaz
Dolayısıyla hayatı anlamlı kılan
başarısızlıklar dır başarı insana gurur
verir bu
bu hırsızlık insanı geliştirir
Dolayısıyla diyemeyiz ki hayatın bütün
iyilikleri benim tarafıma gelsin ama
kötü el kime giderse gitsin böyle bir
şey Mümkün değil Dolayısıyla
mühendislerin hoşuna gidecek bir denklem
hazırladım bunu sadeleştir sake gerçek
hayat ne oluyor Orhan yatın içinde biraz
mutluluk var biraz mutsuzluk var
Dolayısıyla ben size ben size dünyada en
iyi insan olmak gibi Gerçekçi olmayan
bir hedefin arkasından koşmak yerine
dünyada iyi bir insan olmak gibi çok
daha anlamlı ve çok daha etkili bir amaç
sunmak istiyorum ve Aziz Nesin'in bir
dizisiyle bitirmek istiyorum insanlar
gider şarkılar kalır şarkılar var uzun
yüzyılları Dolanır şarkılar var kısa
Söylendiği yerde kalır sizin şarkınızı
nsesi Ajan yılları içine alan yüzyılları
içine alan bir şarkı olmasını ile Sağ ol
abone ol